[Music]
How is Cristian Cásseres greeting you with
his new News Now program in
Spanish? The mother accused of killing your
7-year-old son Liam and you and leaving
his body on the banks of State Route
160 last month will be
extradited to  las vegas' will face
murder charges here se menta moreno
rodriguez 35 years old was arrested in
denver colorado she will be transferred to
clark county to continue her case
the state will continue efforts
to get more people
the coronavirus vaccine governor
styps  slack launched the dax never
days program all people who have
received at least the first dose of
the kobe 19 vaccine will participate in
the draw in which 5
million dollars in prizes
will be distributed the winners will be announced every Thursday
starting next 8  from July until
August 26 and for those people
who still do not want to get vaccinated there will be a
clinic this Saturday in downtown Las
Vegas  for those retirees in the
center of león located on j street
near lake mire boulevard this
clinic will open its doors at 3 in the
afternoon and will last until
no appointment is needed and
the heat wave continues with temperatures very
dangerous, we will continue with the
extreme heat alert until 8 pm
on Sunday, meanwhile we will
reach 114 degrees by Friday,
however we will have a
hot weekend with temperatures
exceeding 110 degrees.
good day